[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a chinese action film called
kung fu chefs
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
wang ping yi works as a chef in a
village in china he is also the bearer
of the dragon head cleaver a symbol of
power to his clan everyone from the clan
knows and respects him much to his
nephew wong kai joe's annoyance kaijo
believes that he should be the rightful
owner of the sacred cleaver since his
father was the last owner one day ping
yi and his clan are hired to work for a
huge gathering organized for the higher
officials of the village ping yi's
disciple accidentally burns the pork
which was supposed to be the main dish
he scolds the guy and takes it upon
himself to slaughter and cook the pig in
less than 30 minutes using the sacred
cleaver he cuts the pig with precision
in only a few seconds half an hour later
the dish is ready to be served ping yi
adds some salt to the dish as a
finishing touch not knowing that his
disciple has mixed a drug in it under
kaijo's order the dish is arranged
beautifully and served to the guests
soon they start to fall down because of
the drug and the blame falls upon ping
yi's cooking he realizes what his
disciple has done and asks him for the
reason the guy pushes him aside and runs
away scared of being caught ping yi runs
behind him but is stopped by a group of
men who accuse him of trying to poison
them besides being a cook ping yi is
also an excellent martial artist he
single-handedly takes on the group of
men and defeats them all at last he
finally catches his disciple and is
about to hit him with a cleaver when his
associate stops him he belittles ping yi
for trying to blame others for his
mistake before ping yi can explain
himself he is kicked out of the village
deemed unworthy to be the owner of the
dragon cleaver somewhere else in the
school of martial arts and cooking a
teacher organizes a competition between
his students he announces that the one
who can put the school's emblem back to
its original place will receive a
special gift the students go crazy to
get the emblem and start fighting each
other one of them named lung kenyatt
climbs on top of the tables kicks the
others away and acquires it but the
others attack him before he can put the
emblem back amidst the chaos the emblem
lands on the teacher's hand and the
students attack him as well during a
chase kenyatt gets his hands on the
emblem and puts it back on the platform
without anyone seeing him during the
lunch break the teacher comes to the
cafeteria looking for kenyatt he plays a
prank on the teacher and gets into a
friendly fight with him kenyatt proves
his talent by fighting using just a roll
of dough and turning it into noodles at
the same time the teacher advises him to
meet a cook named shum fong kwan he
believes that kenyatt has learned
everything he can from the school but he
has yet to learn about the deep idea of
food later kenyatt leaves looking for
the master chef shum fung kwan to start
his training the master chef works in a
restaurant named four seas the owner of
the restaurant shum chang is looking for
several different recipes to improve the
ratings her sister chum ying helps her
with the process but the sisters are
distressed because the dishes are not up
to their standard kenyatt arrives
looking for shum and is asked to wait at
the same time ping yi also arrives at
the hotel to enjoy traditional cantonese
food ching offers ping yi some tea and
is surprised when he can tell apart
their secret ingredient from only one
sip to test the hotel's chef shum ping
yi orders traditional chinese food
called the water cabbage the chef brings
the dish and asks for pingie's opinion
on it when he calls the food bland shum
gets offended and challenges ping yi to
a cookout since they will need an
assistant kinyat offers to help ping yi
ching wants to create innovative dishes
for her restaurant so she doesn't object
after some time both the chefs present
their dishes shume's signature chicken
is delicious but on tasting pingi's
traditional chicken the sisters are
amazed a flashback shows us that he
coated the chicken with sugar syrup to
make it remain boiling from the inside
as described in the traditional recipe
books he didn't even use a knife to cut
the pieces shum accepts his defeat and
resigns from his position as a cook in
the restaurant in his place ching
appoints both ping yi and kin yat as the
head chef and the helper that night she
finds out that pingie's brother who
taught him everything about cooking is
also her father's student she is more
than happy to have someone like ping yi
as their head chef because his cooking
style and principles are identical to
her father's to see if ping yi is really
as talented as he seems kenyatt
challenges him to a fish cutting
competition kenyatt chooses a globe fish
for his dish it needs very skilled
cutting abilities to chop the fish
without losing its original taste
kenyatt impresses ping yi with his
skills with this one when it's ping yi's
turn he uses a normal prime fish for the
dish he slices off parts of its flesh
and leaves the fish alive even after
making a dish out of it both ching and
kenyatt are shocked to see that the fish
can still swim they register that no one
can compete against pingi's cutting
skills the next day at work kenyatt is
ready to learn things from his new
master to his disappointment ping yi
gives him the task to sharpen the knives
he stays up the entire night to complete
the task and gets it done by the morning
but when he shows it to ping yi the cook
is still not impressed he says that
before teaching him how to cook he will
have to learn to cut meat and vegetables
since slicing mincing and grinding
technique are the basics of a great cook
kenyat is given the responsibility to
cut all the vegetables that are used in
the restaurant
pingi's nephew kai joe who was
responsible for him getting kicked out
of the village also owns a restaurant in
the city that is a rival to the four
seas restaurant he hates his uncle for
being the reason his father left the
village a long time ago
chef shum meets kai joe asking to be
hired as a chef in his restaurant now
that he has resigned from his old job
but kaijo says they already work with a
master chef and do not need his services
when he finds out that the uncle he
hates works for his rival restaurant he
is agitated kai joe's right-hand man
liung who was a village member a long
time ago suggests he forget about the
rivalry since he cannot go against his
uncle this angers him even more and he
almost beats liang to death a flashback
shows us that kaijo's father wang ping
kay was a great cook but with time he
turned into an alcoholic ping yi was
against his brother being the bearer of
the dragon cleaver because of this one
night they got into a fight which ended
when kai heard his hand making him
unable to cook after leaving ping yi in
charge of his son he left the village
but kaijo still blames ping yi for his
father's disappearance and wants revenge
back in the present kenyatt continues to
cut the vegetables for two weeks
straight during this time he playfully
bickers with ying and starts liking her
ping yi teaches his techniques to all
the restaurant employees including ying
and kenyatt their ratings soon go up
because of his innovative dishes one
night kaijo and his associates come to
the restaurant for a meal they put nails
on the dish and blame the cook for
putting their lives in danger somehow
all of the customers are dumb enough to
believe this and they leave the premises
refusing to eat the food kaijo insults
ping-hee but the man remains calm and
apologizes he doesn't want to fight with
his family and understands why his
nephew would hate him in the following
scene kenyatt and ying are at a store
shopping for groceries they are
distressed because after the nail fiasco
they have lost half of their customers
ying notices kai joe is also shopping
for groceries near them still mad at him
for ruining their business she attacks
the guy kaijo's henchmen soon join and
fight against the two kenyatt easily
beats them up in no time while ying
struggles against kaijo at one point
they are surrounded by the rival group
but managed to trick them and run away
while trying to catch their breaths they
see an advertisement for the chef of the
year competition if their chef wins the
competition their ratings will go up
again however when they ask pingie to be
in the competition he refuses it turns
out he had gotten a call from his
village that morning they are asking him
to return because after his departure
nothing has been the same ping yi is
confident in his teachings and asks
kenyatt to represent their restaurant in
the competition the next day kenyatt and
his assistant get ready for the first
round of the competition they are going
against six other chefs but their
biggest opponents are shum and his
partner chef chateau the competition
begins and the chefs make their
signature dishes for the first few
minutes kenyatt contemplates what would
be the best dish to make ching from the
audience suggests he make a horse
platter that is made of pigeon duck and
chicken the dish is complicated to make
because it can overcook pretty easily
but if made correctly it is delicious
kenyatt starts working on his dish in
the meantime chow tow skins an ox's head
to cook a famous szechuan dish an hour
later all the dishes are presented in
front of the judges they critique all of
them but when it comes to kenyat's horse
platter they only have nice things to
say they also seem to enjoy chow toes
dish thoroughly the results are
announced and both chow tow and kenyatt
pass the first round now for the final
round they will have to go head to head
kenyatt and the team celebrate their
first win and start preparing for the
finals when kai joe finds out about this
he sends some thugs to beat up kenyatt
so he wouldn't be present in the next
competition kenyatt fights them to his
best but is locked up in a refrigerator
with ying the following day he somehow
manages to escape with ying's help and
is back in the competition
in the village kaijo goes to meet his
uncle to kill him once and for all ping
yi is attacked by a group of thugs who
he fights bravely even after getting
beaten up pretty badly he manages to
send them away and teach his nephew a
lesson he has a chance to kill kai joe
but he doesn't because he still thinks
of him as family in the meantime the
cooking competition begins this time the
chefs are told to make a simplistic soup
dish but without any seasoning this
means they will have to make it
flavorful using only the main
ingredients chow toe quickly starts to
cook a traditional chicken soup while
kenyatt thinks about ping yi's teachings
he remembers the cabbage and water dish
that pingie had ordered when he first
came to the restaurant it has only three
ingredients with no seasoning and if
cooked with the right technique the
simple dish will blow people's minds he
starts to cook it right how pingy had
taught him he uses minced chicken mixed
with water for the soup following that
he pokes holes in the cabbages to run
the soup through them and make it
flavorful chow toe on the other hand
uses a traditional oven to cook his
chicken soup thoroughly however he uses
more ingredients than kenyatt and goes
slightly against the rules ping yi
arrives there and compliments kenyatt
for doing his best at last the judges
are served with two equally appetizing
dishes at first they try chaoto's soup
and are mind-blown by the flavors but
when they try kenyatt's dish they simply
close their eyes and stay frozen
enjoying its simplicity
chow toe goes to one of the judges and
tries his leftovers when he gets a taste
he simply takes his hat off accepting
defeat kenyatt and the team celebrate
the win ping yi even hands him the
dragon head cleaver as a gift to
everyone's surprise pingie's older
brother who had disappeared years ago
arrives at the set he reconciles with
ping yi and even tries the cabbage water
dish a few weeks later all of them are
at the restaurant kenyatt has decided to
go on a tour with ping yi to learn about
all the different cuisines in the world
in the last scene he promises his
girlfriend ying to return soon
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching